our other top story the animal
foundation breaking its silence on
issues it's facing good afternoon thanks
for joining us I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm
Christian Casitas well this weekend
eight intake staff members quit and
unexpectedly and this is not the only
issue that they're facing Victoria Saha
at a news conference that wrapped up not
too long ago Victoria what have you
learned
yeah the admissions Lobby is back open
today at the animal foundation it's
normally where they would do intake for
lost and found but yesterday they had to
close because a large group had walked
out now the shelter says they are at a
critical point
the animal foundation says it's
desperate for foster families to help
free up space at the shelter with over 2
000 animals taken in just this month
alone on Sunday staff at the admissions
say they felt the need to quit 8 news
now received a statement from the staff
members that resigned this weekend they
cited the unstable working conditions
that played a huge role in their
resignation saying they had to work up
to 10 plus hours without a break CEO
Hillary gray responded
it just broke my heart that our team
members felt like they didn't have
another path but to make the choice to
leave I take responsibility for this
we're going to work through it and we're
going to talk about these issues
gray says she's working with Animal
Control Officers to work on scanning for
microchips on the animals out in the
field when returning them to the owner
instead of bringing it to the shelter
CEO gray says she is hopeful the
employees who left will come back I did
bring up that letter we got from the
staff that quit and she says that she's
going to be going over pay and
scheduling as well so these employees
don't feel overwhelmed Victoria Saha
eight news now thank you Victoria the
shelter is in need of foster families
for the animals there so if you are
interested staff will be there at the
shelter until 7 PM this evening